the last time that i spoke to you was
actually at the launch of billy eilish's
album it was like for her it was the
party
so how do you guys know each other um
so we had dm a couple times and then
sadly the first day we met was actually
they did it uh x had passed she came to
my house
and we just listened to his music and
cried all day like some little [ __ ]
but
yeah but yeah and ever since then we've
been real tight yeah it's
kind of like when beauty comes out of
tragedy right it's like friendships are
born out of
hard times a lot of fans are wondering
if you guys
are still friends um people always want
to act like we have problems if we had
beef
no i just feel like either someone got
into her
ear about me and you know made her think
that i was a bad person or she just
didn't
she was getting too big to where she
didn't want to associate herself with my
brand
and that's perfectly fine i understand
that but it's just like
you know it sucks when you have a friend
and they just disappear but i'm not mad
at her she's not mad at me it is what it
is
yeah it i only asked because it sounded
like
when i asked you like how you guys met
and you really bonded over the death was
it of
x yeah yeah and so i feel like
you guys had this connection and it was
so nice of you to like show up and like
support
uh yeah i always supported her i was
always there but you know
it happens yeah you guys haven't talked
recently
no chance of a collaboration that's not
on me
i don't think her team would ever let
her come close to me
but why why do you say that
just you know a lot of people just don't
want to associate themselves with my
brand people think i'm just this evil
devil child so i understand i get it if
there was a kid in school that i thought
was crazy i wouldn't want my kid hanging
out with them either you have this new
song and video out
um it's called do it like me
it's been viewed over 1.7 million
times how does that feel when you hear
that
um i mean i've been hearing this since i
was like 13 that my songs have been
doing crazy so
i'm i'm kind of used to it at this point
but it still feel good
what what has the reception been like in
your opinion i mean are you seeing a
crazy influx of of people loving it
yeah a lot of people are realizing that
like
i'm not the same little badass kid i was
when i was like five years ago so
a lot of people like oh i actually like
her now oh there's really nothing wrong
with her oh like you know what i'm
saying so
is is that weird for you like why do you
think people are suddenly having this
change of heart and understanding that
you're an artist
i feel like because everyone expected me
to just be around for like five minutes
and just disappear
so i feel like they're kind of like oh
we can't push her out okay we might as
well just accept it and she actually
isn't that bad so
do you feel like you had to prove
yourself over these past few years
because of that
um i don't feel like i necessarily
had to but i just by me being me it just
showed like
there's something wrong with me okay i
just run around with a gun and a knife
trying to kill people
all day like did people think that
that's like who you were
yeah literally like when i would do
interviews would be like oh i was scared
you were gonna hit me or something it
would just be like
what why would i just come into a room
and hit you